Lucas in New Zealand says he's a
question about ambition how do I stay
mindful of my personal values despite
contrary professional values being
thrust upon me in the workplace and I
guess the the question that would have
pin to this is does ambition help more
than it hurts or is it actually harmful
is it is ambition toxic in a way
certainly can be toxic I mean it's it's
not yeah I mean that there is the the
totally egocentric narcissistic
pathology of ambition and that hence
hence the question but on some level it
can be purified by a different set of
goals I mean like like you can you can
look if you just want to be famous
that's one thing I might put that on the
the toxic side and it's also on the
confused side because you're not
recognizing all the downsides that come
with Fame but you can also just want
agency because you realize there's an
opportunity to do a lot of good in the
world right like you could just you just
want to be able to get your good ideas
out there or have interesting
conversations at a higher and higher
level right so so yeah I think you can
draw a lot of energy that is very
positive and can be motivated by
compassion and interest and curiosity
and compassion
you know dialed all the way up in terms
of things that kind of the energy can
look a lot like ambition you know they
could be so you ever see somebody just
wants to make art and loves making art
and then finds an audience that
appreciates that art and then all of a
sudden you know whatever your your Lady
Gaga
or somebody who's just at the absolute
summit of Fame and apparently apparent
ambitions realized but you know I'm just
just picking her out of thin air I don't
know if he's ambitious or not but or
egocentric or not but the you could
there's no reason why
couldn't have that level of success and
that level of drive purely for creative
altruistic reasons I mean it's just it's
just energy on that level so there's
there's both forms of it now what about
the values piece here so Lucas is saying
you know how do I say mindful of my
personal values when there are contrary
professional values being thrust upon me
Ryan I think about if you're you're
working a job that is completely out of
line with your values or even halfway
out of line with your values right right
you're gonna feel some some discontent
there yeah there's gonna be some some
pulling and tugging that that you
actually won't be able to do anything
about if you continue to work for that
company
I mean it's when I think about this
question it makes me think about and I'm
gonna butcher this quote from Thoreau
but it's you know something matter being
busy but it's what you're busy about and
I mean that's the question that Lukas
has to ask or anyone else out there
who's seeking fame or you know just
doing work for the sake of work it's
like what are you actually working
towards so at a company where you're
your values are out of alignment that's
that's that's going to lead to a dead
end eventually right yeah I would agree
I think there's you know the framing can
do a lot I mean I think there's there
things that can be stigmatized as
negative which aren't necessarily
negative but obviously there are things
that are negative which which you know
you're going to do there's a a a real
hypocrisy or a real conflict in lending
any energy to that cause if it's not
your cause but I mean they're things
that I guess what I'm trying to carve
out here is that there are things that
can seem superficial and would would not
be on anybody's list of valuable
contributions to society which in
certain circumstances can be quite
valuable let me just like you know just
kind of mindless entertainment right
like if you're working for
if you're producing some show that you
don't think is all that good it's not
professor Tinley not profound in any way
but the reality is is that there are a
lot of people who are living very
stressful lives who by even just tuning
out for 22 minutes on that show are it's
good for them right you know yeah you
know and it's and it's just and this is
Iggy actually this is even true with
meditation I mean so there's some people
who are saying that you know I'm so
stressed out I'm so unhappy there's so
much going on in my life
like I find that if I sit down and
meditate it just feels worse right like
I'm just ruminating about my problems I
mean honestly I would there are many
cases where it would be skillful to just
go watch Game of Thrones right I mean
like if that allows you to forget about
your problems
for that period just to just to provide
some relief that's a that's a can be a
totally skillful reset you know so it's
not it's not that you everything has to
be you know profound all the time but ya
know there's there can be certainly a
there are toxic projects which no
ethical person would want to be
associated with and if you find yourself
part of one of those I think you you've
got to get out I think also there's
profundity profundity in the sort of
banal experiences like we might be doing
something then we might perceive as
banal I'm not really adding value to the
world but because I work changing oil or
an average collector right on the waiter
or waitress these are incredibly
meaningful experience or can be
incredibly meaningful experiences not
just to the person but also the people
that you're serving or you're helping
solve problems I think real society
doesn't function without people like
that yeah I think maybe ask that
question one of the problems I'm helping
solve and doing this job this career or
this mission that I'm working on and
then I think you can find great meaning
in helping other people solve those
problems
you